هل من رد فعل ايراني حتى الان على ما
تنقله القناه
الاسرائيليه عبد السلام لا يوجد حتى الان
اي رد فعل من قبل ايران لا على المستوى
السياسي ولا على المستوى العسكري سواء من
قبل الجيش الايراني او الحرس الثوري
الايراني والذين قواتهما متواجده في
المياه الخليجيه في بحر عمان في شمال
المحيط الهندي وحتى في البحر الاحمر
ل حمايه التجاره الدوليه وخاصه السفن
التجاره التجاريه الايرانيه بشكل اساسي
لكن في التحليل عبد السلام يمكن القول هنا
ان الخبراء الايرانيين المراقبين
الايرانيين دائما خلال ايام الحرب على غزه
كانوا يقراون في اي اتهامات لايران بانها
محاوله من اسرائيل لاجل التغطيه على ما
يوصف هنا بالجرائم جرائم الحرب
الاسرائيليه في غزه او الاباده الجماعيه
في قطاع غزه او حتى ماي يصفه الايرانيون
بانه فشل اسرائيلي في خوض المعارك سواء
على المستوى البري او حتى على المستويات
الاخرى في مواجهه المقاومه الفلسطينيه على
راسها حركه حماس اذا يقرا هنا بالدرجه
الاولى على المستوى التحليلي على انه تهرب
او نقل ال التغطيه الى ان ان يكون هناك
شيء مع ايران تهربا من ما يسمى هنا الفشل
الاسرائيلي من ناحيه اخرى ايضا طهران
دائما كانت تقول انها ليست مع توسيع نطاق
الحرب على غزه وحذرت تكرارا ومرارا من هذا
الامر وقالت ان هناك جماعات مقاومه فصائل
مقاومه مسلحه في المنطقه يمكن ان ترد على
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وما يرتكب من
اباده جماعيه بحق اهالي سكان قطاع غزه هنا
قصد به في الدرجه الاولى جماعه الحوثيين
انصار الله في اليمن بالدرجه الثانيه ايضا
على نفس المستوى ربما اكثر حزب الله في
لبنان وعلى مستوى اخر الفصائل العراقيه
المسلحه المواليه لايران في العراق هنا
تقول ايران ان هذه الفصائل هذه الاحزاب
الرسميه ال ال التي تمتلك السلاح يمكنها
ان ترد بشكل او باخر ضد الجرائم
الاسرائيليه التي ترتكب في قطاع غزه وان
هذا الامر يتخذ بقرار من نفسها من تلقاء
نفسها وبحسب ما تحدده هي وبحسب المصالح
الوطنيه لهذه الدول سواء في العراق في
لبنان في اليمن وان طهران لا تامر هذه
الاحزاب والفصائل والحركات وانها لا تتلقى
الاوامر من قبل طهران اذا اليوم تتحد لا
تتحدث طهران عن اي استهداف ل هكذا سفينه
اسرائيليه قرب الهند لا تعلق على هذا
الامر لكنها تحذر من ان الجرائم
الاسرائيليه في غزه هي ما قد يوسع نطاق
الحرب ولا يجعله محصورا في قطاع غزه وان
استمرار هذه الحرب سوف يهدد الامن والسلم
الاقليمي اليوم مساعد قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني لشؤون التنسيق كان قد حذر ايضا
في نفس الاطار قال انه سابقا واجهت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحتى اسرائيل
مشاكل في مضيق هرمز وهو كان يشير بالدرجه
الاولى الى الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه كذلك
قال ان السفن اليوم تواجه مشكله في باب
المندب وهو يقصد هنا الحوثيين واستهدافهم
للسفن الاسرائيليه او السفن التي تتجه الى
المواني الاسرائيليه لكنه ايضا حذر من ان
هذه السفن قد تواجه مستقبلا مشاكل اخرى في
المتوسط في مضق جبل طارق حتى حذر من ان
العامل الاساسي لاجل هذا التصعيد هذا
التوتر هو الجرائم التي ترتكب في قطاع غزه
من قبل اسرائيل وفي الدرجه الثانيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي توصف هنا
بانها الداعم الرئيس للحرب على غزه من
خلال ارسال الاسلحه الدعم المالي العسكري
والاعلامي وحتى استخدام حق النقض الفيتو
في مجلس الامن الدولي لاجل منع اي وقف
للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه